that's all so big even I have heard it
when sing it to me on The Tonight Show
Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani get
flirty on the voice again you used to
call me on my cell phone late night when
you need my Lou that's contestant Amy
vastrel performing a sexy acoustic
rendition of Drake's hotline bling a
song Gwen and Blake sing together on The
Tonight Show last month
and I know when that hotline bling bling
Amy's performance not only while the
coaches it brought out their flirty side
I don't think there's ever been a more
elegant and classy performance of a song
about a booty call
in the history of music that's all
that's all so big that even I have heard
it when sing it to me on The Tonight
Show
I'm definitely better than the version
that we did on Fallon for sure 100% the
steamy moment had Adam Levine Fanning
himself while Pharrell just couldn't
shake the giggles way before Monday's
live show et caught up with Sheldon who
played coy about the song he and when
wrote together I'm not saying that I've
written a song with Gwen but I'm not
saying I didn't